and then who wrote these memos is our
guest tonight I'm very much looking
forward to asking him about that and
everything else under the Sun I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know enough I don't know enough yeah I
can't answer that I mean I could but I
can't I don't know whether I can answer
that Rachel I don't think I can answer
that as I sit here let me ask you a
related question that I also don't know
if you can answer come on he's you've
got to know something I'm not permitted
to answer that I have no personal
knowledge of it I I don't know anything
about that and if I did I wouldn't say
I'm going to ask me more questions that
you said I don't know I don't know what
I don't know I had no idea I didn't know
I don't know for sure I can't recall
that's another one I can't answer guess
he doesn't know
[Applause]
tomi stormy two peas in a pod one had a
book another had a sketch and they tried
to outdo each other in a game of
publicity ping-pong I thought honestly
that he was you know sort of handsome
you realize I'm actually kind of an
honest idiot I was like bodyguards and
you'd only want to know their food bill
I think I'm a good person where I've
lied my baby it had a blowout and her
diaper
during the salad before the shrimp
scampi not a better actress than Pia it
might be green men out there women like
me matter I don't want to be too tough
on myself I'm done being bullied
it sucked oh yeah
now as for those Comey memos I got more
of a shock taking my tube socks out of
the dryer I'm sorry the collusion seems
more between Democrats and the media
than anyone else but if you're a
Democrat you're thinking crap this stuff
isn't working what do we do now the
Democratic Party has filed a federal
lawsuit in Manhattan against the Russian
government the Russian intelligence
service WikiLeaks and the Trump campaign
alleging damage to the Democratic Party
as a result of the hack in the 2016
presidential election that's amazing
they're suing Russia they're suing
Russia
there's another new avenue to and seat
the president because all the other
previous ones are dead ends it's my
golden rule when idiots don't get what
they want Basu now judging by all the
coverage you think that was it for the
week well not so my friends over Easter
Mike Pompeo met kim jeong-hoon he said
that Pompeyo had a great meeting and
that they're setting up this summit if
you will it's a first this is the
highest level contact between the North
Korean leadership and the United States
leadership in the history of the two
things so we find out about the meeting
on Tuesday night by Friday where you're
in North Korea was suspending its
nuclear and long-range missile tests you
had nothing important here it's
certainly not up there with a rich guy
banging a porn star actually if Kim is
true to his word this is to quote Joe
Biden from years ago a big deal even the
even the guy on CNN admitted it this is
an extraordinarily significant
development and frankly a huge win for
president Trump came as a funny voice
this could be super huge this could be
up there with the Berlin Wall coming
down the collapse of the Soviet Union
the breakup of minuto was for me and I
got to wonder it has to be hard on all
those other networks how do they cover
something this monumental if trump's
responsible and what if dennis rodman
helped
it's possible I owe him an apology
Bacchus if Trump solves North Korea make
some room for him on Rushmore and if you
factor in other accomplishments Isis the
economy China you might need to clear
off the whole damn mountain so where
does this leave the never Trump erse
laughing for car accidents terrible
audience we have here it's time for an
intervention think about what they're
doing obsessing over a decade old sex
romp while the world stage changes now
think about the collapse of the USSR
what if the MSNBC's of today were around
back then they'd be doing a town hall on
the secret sexism of leg warmers
but I get it what if the person you hate
changes the world for the better maybe
learn a few lessons for example you
don't have to like someone to appreciate
their skill set I mean yeah maybe Trump
is like a Mafia don
but maybe a mafia mafia Don is what you
need to get certain people to listen
Trump said fire and fury in the media
laughed but Kim didn't he got it
it was his language Trump seems to do
this with every issue and it works his
presence it's like a laxative in a
brownie he gets everyone going I think
I've used that joke before
and yeah even I admit it's it's crazy if
the guy from The Apprentice brings world
peace it's crazy and as for those of you
who find it unsavory that the same guy
slept with a porn star well we all can't
be as pure or as boring as you are that
is if you're a billionaire living the
life in New York City I think it's
against the law if you don't sleep with
a porn star but for all you generic
anti-trump errs it's time to admit this
whole stormy saga has really got nothing
to do with defending the honor of a porn
star you don't care about her she's just
a prop to be used to unseat a president
she was used in films and now she's
being used on cable news it's all just
an extended bitter tantrum caused by an
election which is fine
but if your petty emotions get in the
way of something that could make the
world a better and safer place then
you're a loser and you will not be
invited to the Korean unification party
to be held at an undetermined location
but I'm thinking it's Dobbs place
no joke he has a hot tub that seats 240